select committee we're live in the
Palace of Westminster in the House of
Commons and this morning is our first
evidence session into our new inquiry
into assisted dying assisted suicide it
is a subject that obviously is
incredibly sensitive and affects us all
which is how we die
um obviously some people feel incredibly
strongly about there being the need for
a change in the law some people feel
incredibly strongly that there shouldn't
be a change in the law and many people
are obviously well aware that there is a
debate ready on the subject and
have not picked a position on this and
may never do so
our purpose is to look at all of the
issues and the evidence and to do so as
we always try to do in his most
sensitive way as we can possibly
a call for evidence on this inquiry was
launched at the start of December and to
collect evidence of domestic and
international views on the subject and
just briefly set out for those watching
the terms of reference were things
ranging from to what extent people in
England Wales have access to good
palliative care how that can be improved
and would such improvements negate some
of the arguments for a change in the law
what we can learn from evidence in
countries where the law has already been
changed what are the professional and
ethical considerations involved in
allowing Physicians to assist someone to
end their life
and there are a number of other terms of
reference all of which are available on
our website
in today's session it's the first oral
evidence session for our inquiry we're
going to hear from four peers who've
been involved in work on this topic over
many years including those who attempted
to introduce legislation into the House
of Lords to change the law and then on
our second panel after we'll take a very
short break we'll uh hear from the
current evidence base with academics
with expertise in the fields of
palliative care end of life care and the
experience of healthcare professionals
involved in medically assisted deaths
so let me introduce panel one which is
here before us we have baroness Finlay
of Lander we have Lord faulconer
authoriton we have baroness mitcha and
we have baroness Hollins thank you so
much for giving up your time and
speaking to us at the very start of what
is an incredibly high profile inquiry
we're aware that there is huge public
interest in this the amount of evidence
that we received the amount of replies
to our survey has surpassed any
expectations and my clerks are thrilled
with the uh tens of thousands tens of
tens of thousands of replies that we
received but I just like to place on
record my thanks to them because it has
been a huge volume of work that has come
into them
before I open up the floor to my
colleagues I just wanted to to ask each
of you to you know not discussing the
law not discussing the procedures I just
wanted to ask each of you to speak from
the heart and to tell us
why you care
I said at the start some people care
deeply on both sides of this
um why do you care so much maybe if I
could start with a former Lord
Chancellor Lord Faulkner why do you care
so much sir well I'm like everybody else
in
this is your own policy which is I
myself have had personal involvement in
somebody dying somebody dying who
appoint is reached where it turned out
that there were weeks to go but there
was nothing left except an increasing
Focus for the person who was dying on
their inward suffering where death was
absolutely inevitable and where it was
absolutely clear that
her assisting herself to die would have
been unquestionably the best course but
that was not possible so a long period
went on where there was
how can I judge this quite bad suffering
for her and bad suffering for those who
loved her
after that experience which is what
started my involvement I then got
interested in the issue for obvious
reasons I wondered whether or not
palliative care being better for
everybody because it should be better
for everybody would make the difference
as it happened the person who I've just
referred to was in the Health Service
and therefore quite high quality Care
was given and that desperately needs to
be an improvement in positive care but
it's absolutely clear that improving
creative care will not resolve the needs
of some people to end their life in the
context of a terminal illness earlier
there's widespread Sympathy for the
position that I adopt indeed the law has
turned itself on its head with the law
being it's a crime to assist somebody to
commit suicide but the law will not be
enforced by the DPP because everybody
accepts it's a nonsense of a law
there needs to be safeguards as it
happens the assisted dying proposal is
now the most sick if it became law would
be the most safeguarded route
to an earlier death because it's more
safeguarded than withdrawing your own
treatment the hospital deciding you're
not going to be treated if you're under
the care of the court of protection and
the doctors in your family agree then
you won't get assist then you can have
that stopped without any intervention so
it's the most safeguarded
where have we got to know it's such a
mess
the law now
we will allow people to go to
Switzerland we will allow people to be
helped to go to Switzerland we'll
investigate their loved ones when they
come back which is a hellish
experience the law is such a mess and I
don't think I've met anybody who doesn't
think that
and the law itself recognizes that I
think it's time for a change thank you
very much baroness Hollins if I come to
you next why why did you want to come
and speak today why do you care so
passionately about this subject
as a doctor as a psychiatrist
um
I am very very worried about and as a
legislator I'm very worried about the
unintended consequences and I think no
country in the world has succeeded in
creating a law which
um actually protects people who find
themselves in vulnerable situations so
that is my main main reason and I think
one of our real difficulties and what is
I've been it's like five percent of the
world currently has access to has access
to
um physician-assisted suicide that's all
it's um it's a minority and it's not
proven to be safe essentially and
attempts in previous private members
bills to to make it safer have not been
well received by the proponents of of
the legislation my work on deaf
education for I was a I've been an
academic psychiatrist for 40 years but
my work teaching medical students for
example and community to staff working
in Mental Health Services
all the time we found fear about talking
about death we don't have adequate death
education in our society though it is
driven by fear and this is one of the
big big reasons for me I would like to
see a much more accepting conversation
about death
um which is which is an acceptance that
this is something that is going to
happen to all of us and it's a normal
process and the more we talk about it
the more there is a possibility that
people will get the help they need when
they're dying so that they can die
um in Comfort with family and friends
around them without all the anxiety that
goes around around a sister's suicide
um I've been teaching
more recently through a charity that I
set up books beyond words within schools
which has been fabulous to begin to talk
to Children who've been bereaved
um you know parents die I think there's
a parent dies every 20 minutes or
something in the United Kingdom there
was something like every class will have
at least one child who's been bereaved
with a parent
and yet teachers are not comfortable
talking about death and we've been
trying to introduce ways to do that so
that's really really important as a
clinician just see and as a researcher
just seeing how the people that I
particularly concerned about people with
learning disabilities and autistic
people how their lives are not are not
valued and how their own lack of
confidence in their own quality of life
can lead to kind of changes and
perception of those who are caring for
them we saw it during the pandemic how
people with Down Syndrome had a six
times higher death rate a lot of that
was due to do not resuscitate
assumptions being made about quality of
life my research in the Netherlands has
found that the Netherlands is unusual in
that they actually
provide case histories of people who've
had euthanasia and it is normally
euthanasia in the Netherlands I think 96
of cases because it's easier it's more
effective because the complication rate
from physician-assisted suicide is so
high and so the learning disability and
autism Community we didn't expect to
find that they were represented among
those euthanized but they were we found
in our study 38 cases described this is
it will be an underestimate because
they're not all just described we found
38 cases of people with learning
disability and or Autism who were
euthanized simply because of the
symptoms of having a learning disability
or Autism that's a sort of safeguard
that I suppose I'm concerned about I'll
stop there but
um okay thank you for that's a very good
setting of the scene and then baroness
means you introduced legislation on this
subject but staying away from that
because we'll come on to the nuts and
bolts but why why are you so identified
with the subject and wanting a change
now why do you care so much what's your
lived experience should declare my
interest as chair of dignity and dying
indeed
Social Work under Quaker and I suppose
I've just spent my life really
trying to listen to people's needs
trying to reduce unbearable suffering
and trying to protect vulnerable people
at the moment people some people have to
choose between suicide
uh suffering or Switzerland future
Generations are going to be appalled
that we've taken so long to put this
right
we think of patient autonomy for many
years polls and surveys have shown that
the huge majority of British people want
an assisted dying law
86 percent of disabled people want this
a disabled that they want a terminal
sorry an assisted dying law for people
who are terminally illness ill and who
are mentally competent it's very clear
that is where the support lies both for
non-disabled people and disabled people
we know that choice and some control at
the end of life will be in tremendous
Comfort to dying people
relieving unbearable suffering
terminal illness brings unbearable
suffering in various forms
obviously uncontrollable physical pain
is one such form but another is endless
nausea and vomiting maybe because of
opioids and an allergy to anti-emetics
another is fecal vomiting which can
recur and recur another is a fumigating
fumigating tumor creating the most
appalling uh odor
that the patient cannot get away from
other people don't want to come into the
ward because of the odor the patient
cannot leave it or a complete and utter
loss of the ability to move maybe
because of motor neurone disease these
patients at the end of towards the end
of life are unable to swallow to speak
to eat to drink this they're existing
they're not living we all want more and
better palliative care of course we do
but that will but however good
palliative care is it will not be able
to eliminate the unbearable suffering of
many of these people
protecting vulnerable people at the
moment people patients stop eating and
drinking
they stop taking their medication
they'll leap off a bridge they'll try
hanging themselves
there are no safeguards or regulations
to check that these people are not under
coercion from a nearest relative to
shorten their life an assisted dying
bill will introduce really strong
safeguards involving two doctors of
course
and the succession of interviews with
the patient to make sure that they
really have a sustained wish for help to
die and and interviews with relatives to
check their their motives too
Jeff Whaley and Andy Safra who went to
Switzerland wrote to every MP
complaining of hypocrisy and cruelty of
the current law and pleaded with MPS to
change the law so that others would not
have to suffer as he had suffered
but what about Healthcare professionals
my daughter's a doctor I'm very
conscious of the historical
issues around a sister dying for doctors
in particular nurses but of course the
medical professionals has changed
tremendously over recent years
the BMA and
the Royal College of Physicians for
example were opposed they're now neutral
having consulted their members why
because the fbma survey for example the
largest survey of doctors on this
subject ever found that far more doctors
were in support of assisted dying them
are against it 50 supported and 39
percent
were opposed and internationally things
have changed too the number of states in
the U.S that now have assisted dying
legally have more than doubled in recent
years all the states of Australia New
Zealand have all legalized assisted
dying since 2017 countries are on the
Move in Europe and and also of course
Scotland the Isle of Man and Jersey okay
thank you uh for setting the scene that
way and then just just finally Baron
Finley
um your your experience that drives you
to to speak publicly on this sensitive
subject I thank you
um I should declare I'm a palliative
medicine physician I've worked in the
field since
1987 and I have looked after thousands
and thousands of dying patients as well
of course having my own experience of
people very close to me dying
I've had many many conversations with
people who are dying people who are in
absolute despair I had a patient back in
1991 who was desperate for euthanasia
four of us thought that his prognosis
was three months
he with great difficulty and I was there
till 11 at night persuaded him that I
would try and relieve his symptoms and
he said he'd give me two weeks before he
killed himself
11 years later he phoned me because his
wife was dying
um she died in my care with his children
at her bedside and him in a wheelchair
he is still alive today just an example
of how wrong you can be
in I've had many conversations with
patients where they've said I never
believed that I could feel so much
better again the one thing that
palliative care and assisted dying have
in common is that they are very poorly
understood
and that's a real problem we have the
post shipment effect with opioids
unfortunately and now um clinicians are
reluctant to prescribe the type of dose
which actually many patients need so it
takes a bit longer to get there as for
Nordstrom vomiting I've been involved in
the research and the situation now is
that we can control the intestinal
obstruction well smell from fungating
tumors doesn't happen like it used to I
saw it happen years ago but not today
modern medicine has changed I had the
privilege of working in the Netherlands
with a visiting professor as a visiting
professor and I've been out with the GP
to observe these conversations happening
and it was really striking how you end
up going down one road and the clinical
thinking to think about other ways of
controlling symptoms
it becomes very difficult this was a
very very good GP
I've been involved in providing
education all over the world nowhere
else has got the level of palliative
care education that we have but it has
only been in less than the last year
it's the Health and Care Act which
finally puts pounded care as a core part
of the NHS until now we haven't had that
and that becomes really important I've
seen patients who have been suicidal
have really discussed whether or not
they go to Switzerland but actually
those requests and that suicidal
ideation disappears when they get the
care they need and I think the last
thing I would say is that my own mother
was very strongly in favor of euthanasia
and when she was dying and we thought
she had six weeks to live she was
extremely angry with me that I'd opposed
it
four years later
she said that she was really glad and
that she had had the most incredibly
rewarding time seeing her grandson born
and so on so
I think that was just an illustration to
me I've been on the receiving end of the
conversations on many occasions
okay thank you very much I think it was
important at the very start of this
inquiry to to hear those lived
experiences or opening statements I I
don't like that term but but people know
what what we mean
um for the rest of the session obviously
we just need to keep our answers
significantly shorter than that because
we won't let members come in which is
what what they're here to do
um Chris Green yes
I just want to uh how you judge or what
you're understanding of the change in
perception uh the public would have of
doctors or the medical profession if we
introduce the sister dying or a suicide
I don't think there would be any
significant change in relation to it in
those countries where assisted dying has
become permitted for example in Oregon
uh a significant majority of doctors are
willing to participate in the process
there's no evidence that that had an
impact on people's views in relation to
doctors I think that people look to
their doctor when they are dying and
although I completely agree with what
both Sheila and Elora said about the
fact there's not enough discussion about
death very many people are aware that
they are dying and they look to their
doctor to help them in relation to that
your opening comments
um in terms of the experience of a
friend was quite narrow in terms of how
you set the scope of people who would be
included with the practice of a law that
you'd perhaps favor would that scope be
similarly as narrow or would it be
broader and if it were a broader what
scope
um in a few years Time 5 10 20 years
time would there be for opening up that
scope as far as I am concerned the scope
would be only those who are terminally
ill they would require a diagnosis from
two doctors and a high court judge would
have to say it was okay to go ahead with
an assisted death the period of time
I've suggested is six months there's
been debate about that but broadly only
those who are terminally ill would be
within the scope of the assisted dying
bill that I have proposed and prior to
the bill that I proposed in the laws
Lord joffe proposed a bill he made it
absolutely clear that he wanted to go
wider perhaps to unbearable suffering
I'm incredibly opposed to unbearable
suffering as the root I'm only in favor
of terminal illness Lord Joffrey's bill
was defeated two to one in the Lord's my
effectively got through unopposed of a
second reading and when there were votes
they were all in favor because the
terminal illness scope is the one that I
favor if you start with a terminal
illness scope then history tells us
looking at other countries that it
doesn't expand
you can go for two routes you can go for
unbearable suffering on the one hand
which is I mean this is not the only
country where it's been done but if you
look at the low countries it's been done
there or you can go for a terminal it
was part of the way that you help people
when they are terminally ill which is
more the Oregon root and by and large
the scope doesn't change in the low
countries or uh Belgium for example were
um you can have a sister diagonal
suicide of children yeah
um
societies change and one of the reasons
why we're having this debate now or
we've had a succession of debates in in
recent years is because the attitudes of
society has changed now once uh assisted
dying becomes more commonplace more
accepted the scope surely there's going
to be pressure to extend the scope and
if it were to include uh other groups
because sister dying across the world is
still relatively new uh there would be
pressure to include wider groups
including children and surely at that
point the perception of the relationship
relationship between a patient and
doctor would change first of all you're
much better able to judge than I am what
public opinion is because I'm an
appointed peer
for what it is worth my view that the
idea that in this country a perception
would arise that it was okay to allow
children to have an assisted death is
completely for the birds that will never
happen in my lifetime I'm sure which has
obviously got a limited span but I mean
I think if you look at it going forward
that seems to me to be incredibly
unlikely my feeling about what the UK
will wear is they they are in favor of
terminal illness assistance but nothing
more and that's absolutely my view and
that's where the Lords have got to thank
you uh Baron Collins the the same
question to you in terms of the
perception of the relationship between
patients and doctors do you think that
would change initially and perhaps would
it change over time
hugely
as a relationship I'll just give one
example in the Netherlands
um a friend of mine's mother was dying
and her mother was being asked every day
would you like to take the drugs now
um because the culture had changed the
culture the assumption is that this is
an option
um and uh and that's my worry that it's
an easy way out on a personal note I
just changed quite clarifying so someone
goes and their anticipation anticipating
medical treatment and they're actually
given an option of uh assisted dying yes
basically and that and that just is is
too difficult and I think it on a
personal note I was visiting a GP with
uh um with a family member who had a
terminal illness and this doctor made it
clear that this was an option that they
would strongly support we changed our
doctor we didn't actually feel
comfortable being with a doctor who even
in that first conversation was Raising
that as a possibility
I mean it's you know talking about
Switzerland for example not something we
wanted to hear we wanted uh to know that
we were going to get all the support and
be directed to the right support right
at the start
um so I just think it does change things
the culture the attitude everything
changes it's such an important
relationship when people are in a
vulnerable situation and you know having
a life-limiting uh diagnosis does make
you vulnerable whoever you are you sure
uh little Faulkner's uh confidence that
if the if it were introduced with very
narrow very clearly defined terms that
that would actually be a sustainable
position over 5 10 20 years
but actually if you look in any other
country where it's been legalized this
has changed and that's the difficulty
for me that it's just and we look in
Canada Canada people talk about Oregon
Canada and the Netherlands are much more
like our legal system and our culture
and and it has just immediately opened
right up and particularly concerned
about the extension to people with
mental illness and to people with um to
disable people and and particularly to
people with learning disability and
autism who are so open to
um to suggestion um very very difficult
conscious of time if I can just go to
baroness meet you and then Baron is
Finley just to comment on what you've
heard so far
well uh
they are an absolute outlier Canada
because unusually the Supreme Court in
Canada
opened up the issue of his sister Dying
by through a judgment
which implied a broader law
the legislature were then Under Pressure
to introduce a sister dying
um and they did so in two stages one to
limit it to terminal people with mental
competence and stage two respected the
decision and Judgment of the Supreme
Court the courts in the UK are
absolutely clear
and we've taken a case through the court
so I'm very very conscious of it the
courts will not make a judgment on this
issue the courts in this in the UK are
absolutely clear this is a matter for
Parliament Parliament will pass a law on
assisted dying when Parliament is ready
to do so that is absolutely crucial and
every the majority of jurisdictions that
have passed laws on assisted dying have
done so restricted to terminal people
who are mentally competent and not a
single one of those jurisdictions has
broadened the scope from the initial
scope that is incredibly important
because that is what I believe will be
the case in the UK where a highly
disciplined income tree that is the
route I believe we will follow we will
have the narrow law for terminal people
who are mentally competent and it will
remain thus okay uh baroness Finley uh
thank you I think it's important to
remember that defining terminal illness
is extremely difficult in the bill that
baroness Mitchell proposed an 18 year
old with anorexia would have been
eligible a diabetic who was insulin
dependent would have been eligible by
refusing their treatment so in that
sense by refusing your treatment you
then have a term or condition is that
well absolutely and we know that sadly
anorexia is a is a potentially vital
condition even now even though our NHS
investment has improved Survival by 22
percent in recent years but it's still a
potentially fatal illness I think you
also have to remember that diagnostic
error is quite
um common there have been cases in
Canada of people who had euthanasia but
actually never had the illness that they
were thought to have one in 20
postmortems show that there's been a
diagnostic error in this country that's
evidence from the College of
pathologists
um we know that the prognosis is in just
about impossible in fact Ray talus in
evidence to the previous Select
Committee in the Lord's described it as
a probabilistic art and the College of
GP said at six months is pretty
desperately hopeless being able to
predict prognosis
um in terms of the the law itself I
think it would only be a very short time
until a challenge was brought in the
courts claiming inequality for whatever
reason if you try to put firm boundaries
around it the Canadian experience I
don't think we can ignore it has split
the medical profession in terms of
Oregon I've understood that only two
percent of doctors there actually
prescribe and are involved in this so to
say that it's widespread it is not
correct it just don't understand that
because the point made before is that in
Oregon there's popular support from
doctors but actually you all saying in
though in terms of those actually
participating it's a far smaller group
so is the question over you might
support it you wouldn't participate in
it yeah and the BMA survey that was
referred to also showed that the highest
opposition was amongst those clinicians
who deal with these patients look after
these patients all the time particularly
my own specialty of part of medicine but
also geriatric medicine clinical
oncology renal medicine that's where the
opposition came when you ask people do
would you be willing to participate in
the processes the numbers go right down
so theoretically they think well that
might be okay but when they think it
through the numbers drop the BMA also
did a study called the end of life at
Elk pad end of life care and palliative
part of an assisted dying study in depth
which is well worth reading and it
showed that the public groups that were
in there as well as the doctors the more
they learned about it the more they
became cautious about it I do think we
have to remember about the drugs that
are actually used nowhere in the world
have these be drugs been approved by any
Authority for repurposing people are
completely unaware last week a hundred
clinicians were asked do you know what
drugs are used this was in Southampton
none of them use the doses it is a
hundred tablets of barbiturate or 150
tablets of a mixture of Valium
amitriptyline digoxin and that's an
awful lot of tablets to swallow the
other thing with euthanasia to over
two-thirds of patients last year in
Belgium were given a short acting
anesthetic agent but then it they also
were given Ferrari meant that meant
every muscle was paralyzed they will
have looked as if they're peaceful but
they were dying of asphyxia people are
just unaware of that and if I can just
add one thing I did ask many years ago
now for somebody to do a study to see
whether patients given these cocktails
in euthanasia regain Consciousness
before they died because there was a
study from lethal um injections in
executions that showed 80 percent of
people probably regained a degree of
Consciousness but nobody's undertaken
that study so we're dealing with
something which is really unknown the
end point yes it's death
but actually I think we can manage death
better and differently we don't have to
go down the route and I do think you you
do have to look at Canada because the
experience in Canada is worrying thank
you could I just correct two things that
baroness Finley said first of all in
relation to Oregon the position is that
the median time to unconsciousness after
ingesting the medication is five minutes
and the median time to death is 30
minutes nobody is reported to have
regained Consciousness with the
medication and the second and separate
I'm sorry nine people have and the
separate the second point is that she
she
suggested and I was surprised by this
that the courts could set aside a bill
that parliament passed for assisted on
which is completely untrue the reason
why Canada is different is because of a
Charter of Rights which allows the
Supreme Court to set aside or require
legislation so I defer to Elora on all
medical matters but on legal matters
that was quite um no we are going to
move on
um what colleague colleagues know that
we won't be asking all four of you on
each question
um because we're you know we've got a
second panel and we're just we're never
gonna
we're never going to get there in
daylight hours at this rate uh Lucy Alan
thank you chair I wanted to ask about
the f
clearly all all medical professionals
want to alleviate suffering of patients
and also there is now a trend for the
profession to move towards choice and
autonomy about care and treatment and
putting the patients at the center of
that so perhaps if I could start with
baroness Hollins do you think that there
is a concern for
the ethical considerations around
medical professionals when they are
being faced with suffering of their
patients and a lack of clarity in the
law
well I think the law the the law is
clear that
um I think the diff the the ethical
issue for the doctor is to
um is to meet the needs of the patient
and if you don't have the adequate
competencies yourself to refer to
somebody who does and we have the the
opportunity in this country to refer to
palliative care to palliative medicine
and we have the the so I mean I
I think I think there is
um I mean bonus Finley is probably more
okay with the ethics because I think
you're still on the Ethics Committee at
the BMA so you might prefer to to
address this with with with her just to
give it a bit of um a bit more a bit
more sort of context say for example a
doctor was faced with a terminal patient
who was suffering Gravely and that
doctor decided to give that patient a
little bit too much morphine
no I think that's a misunderstanding
people misunderstand uh Morphine
Morphine
the way that morphine is used is to
titrate it again it's not my specialism
but I I was a GP for a number of years
as and I've been a psychiatrist and I've
I've been involved in a lot of debates
discussions around this but
um and I've also seen and been with
family members who've needed Morphine at
the end of their life and there's often
a reluctance to take it because there's
an assumption that if you take too much
morphine it will kill you it's not
really like that if you keep on top of
the pain the morpheme will actually
allow you in the end to die it's not
that it kills you but it allows you to
die my understanding is that it's pain
that keeps you keeps you in suffering
but if you take morphine then the
natural process of dying can take place
it's about skill and titrating the dose
again this is baroness Finley's
expertise
I think it that there is a real
misunderstanding if you're in the street
and you don't have pain and you take an
overdose of morphine then yes you may
stop breathing and that would kill you
in our patients you titrate the dose of
morphine against the pain to be below
the level of toxicity I've seen patients
who've had an accidental overdose
sometimes huge because someone got the
dose wrong for whatever reason they just
have a good sleep and wake up again
afterwards it's really difficult to kill
people with morphine that's why the
mixtures used in those countries are not
based they're not overdoses of morphine
the patient says to a doctor yes is can
you give me more morphine and the doctor
thinks this will probably finish the
patient off
is that not an ethical dilemma for that
doctor that they would be outside the
law but acting in accordance with the
request of their suffering patient I
think sadly that I'd say that probably
reflects the degree of ignorance of the
way that the opioids work but also how
to handle it if somebody says I'm
suffering unbearably you must go back
find out why diagnose what the
underlying cause is and think again
morphine isn't the only way of relieving
pain there are lots of other ways as
well you may have to involve other
people get other people in but actually
people are terrified of pain of course
they are nobody wants to be in pain but
it isn't the main reason either that
people go for assisted suicide so if you
look at the Oregon Data the main reasons
are about being a burden
pain or fear of pain comes way down the
list and I would stress fear of pain
because actually we don't know how many
of the people actually had unrelief pain
isn't the problem though what about
patients being
able to make their own choices and
patient autonomy so if you're if you're
dying you know you have limited lifespan
left you are in pain your family seeing
you suffer patient autonomy is something
that the medical profession is moving
towards in terms of choice and placing
the patient at the heart of what is done
what what sort of ethical considerations
are raised by that the thing about
choice is that you must have information
choices meaningless unless it's an
informed choice and you need to know
what the options are and have them
available I pointed out that we've only
just Incorporated palliative care as
part of a requirement for NHS provision
we still have parts of the UK where it's
not available and it needs to be
but we are getting there in terms of the
patient's Choice as well you have to ask
why what what's behind that request to
end their life what is going on if you
look at suicide rates overall suicide
rates the ons did some work and it was
misinterpreted because what it showed is
that people given a serious life
limiting diagnosis are at highest risk
of suicide at the time that they get the
bad news and their suicidal risk drops
down with time afterwards
if you if you look at suicide rates in
countries that have gone down this road
they're all higher than us our suicide
rate
um in the UK is 8.4 400 000 in Oregon
it's 18.3 that's not assisted suicide
those are mostly gunshot
um suicides so you don't even solve that
problem very limited time and I was sure
about ethical considerations for the
profession
um I wonder Baris Mitch if I could just
ask you about the ethical considerations
uh for the profession given that the law
is and we heard little Faulkner say this
that the law is unclear I mean I'm not
clear of the layperson whether it's the
the doctor's responsibility that the
director of public prosecution's
responsibility the Court's
responsibility Lord Faulkner's clearest
parliament's responsibility if you're a
medic
and you are going to expose yourself to
a law that's not entirely clear
does that create ethical considerations
I suppose I take it the law is clear it
is not acceptable to assist somebody to
die under the current law a doctor will
know that so the ethical consideration
for a doctor in my view is that here
they have a patient suffering unbearably
pleading with them for help to end their
suffering and they can't end that
suffering legally therefore I'm assuming
they won't do it so so that for me is
the ethical dilemma under the current
law which of course an assisted dying
law would eliminate then the autonomy of
the patient would really come to the
fore if the patient really wants to die
is pleading for help to die then a
doctor can help that patient the
important Point here though is that
Laura Finley referred to the six-months
rule in jurisdictions that have
legalized assisted dying people request
the medication and ultimately take it
normally within a week to 10 days of of
the predicted death they don't take it
six months ahead of time and therefore
people are much much clearer very close
to death that this is indeed the future
for this person they will die within a
week to ten days what it means is that
in the lead up to that period the
patient knows when they really get to
the end that they're suffering whatever
it is vomiting fumigating wounds and
they do happen these things
um the the that that unbearable pain
will be able to be ended by a doctor and
it is that
um security and reassurance that is so
important to people and means that dying
people have a much better end of life
experience related added to that of
course you've got the fact that doctors
aren't in these jurisdictions where they
have a sister dying are much more able
to talk openly with patients and there's
a lot of evidence about this thank you
about the patients of problems and
issues bringing law to Faulkner well
while I may
um kirst armor as as director of public
prosecutions made the point in a speech
in 2015
um that relatives
um will be acting very usually for
compassionate reasons and it is
extremely rare that he would have seen
in his capacity as DPP
um any prosecutions against relatives he
did say that medical professionals are
in a slightly different position
um and I wonder if you just comment on
on that point and and you so want to
talk to somebody
when you are terminally ill and you
might want to consider whether or not
you want to take your own life by going
to Switzerland
and illora and the entirely admirable
palliative care professional try to
persuade you not if you talk to a doctor
at the moment in the United Kingdom or
sorry England and Wales not Scotland and
he or she says well look I've heard what
you say you want to go to Switzerland if
they encourage you in any way they may
end up being prosecuted under the law
they will not have the protection of the
DPP statement which only applies to
relatives so the only assistance you can
get under the mess that is the law at
the moment is amateur assistance
well-motivated assistance but amateur
and my experience having looked at this
a lot since my own personal experience
is that people feel alone they do not
want to talk to their own family about
taking their own lives they can't talk
to the doctor so what they do is they
take their own life without telling
anybody and it is absolutely hellish for
those who are left behind thank you
fascinating stuff well done thank you
Lucy right we're gonna go to Rachel
mascal and then Paul blomfield starting
with you Rachel
everybody wants a good death and um
within that without fear as well
um
bonus mitchen and Lord Faulkner if I can
turn to you first we've heard today that
um difficult deaths can be addressed by
palliative care
for instance uh pain
um we've heard about certain tumors
vomiting and and so on can be controlled
so is it that the advances in medicine
which are forever progressing can
actually address that that fundamental
issue about having a good death
all the evidence that I have seen and
I've seen a lot of it suggests that we
all want better better funded palliative
care
but that that will never be able to
eliminate unbearable suffering for
everyone yes for the majority of people
that is so
um but there will always be a minority
of people who will suffer unbearably in
in the ways that I have indicated uh
obviously uncontrollable physical pain
is just one of those those forms of
unbearable suffering I suppose the one
that I see as the most frightening is
the complete loss of ability to move
particularly caused by motor neuron
disease and I met Jeff Whaley who went
to Switzerland and who I referred to in
my own comments and the fact is not to
be able to swallow to speak
uh to eat to drink to scratch an itch to
to deal with a pain not to be able to
move in any way or communicate because
you can't speak any longer and you can't
move to to Signal this is a form of
unbearable suffering
um that I believe where I believe if a
person really cannot cope they should be
assisted to end their suffering and that
was the view of Jeff Whaley that he put
so strongly to every MP in this country
I just ease your house a little bit more
on that issue so somebody for instance
who has a learning difficulty could be
in that situation or a profound
disability which they've had all of
their lives could be in that situation
at all what would you say say to the
person with learning difficulties well
I've worked with people with learning
difficulties severe learning
difficulties and it's remarkable the way
dear people can find a way of
communicating if they're not paralyzed
the fact is complete inability to move
is something completely
you know else if you know what I mean uh
something completely different
trying to come into yeah I've got
nothing to add to what Brandon's meter
said I just want to also pick up with
you about what we've heard very
powerfully today the the lack of a
comprehensive Advance palliative care
system across the country were that to
be available do you believe that would
remove some of the fear people would
have about not being able to access high
quality Care at the end of their life to
either of you I think the better the
palliative care the better the situation
would be for some people but I think
there is a group of people who no matter
how good the palliative care will be
will always find the position they find
themselves as being intolerable
hospice UK said the following it's not
in doubt that some people will have what
they or their families considered to be
a bad death despite the very best care
being made available across all settings
everyone has their own level Beyond
which they may feel their quality of
life has become unacceptable and why you
feel your quality of life has become
unacceptable May in some cases be the
physical
restriction or pain or it may be the
lack of dignity or the lack of control
that makes it impossible but I think
most people who have done work in this
area think there will always be a group
of people who find the idea of what is
coming which may not be pain it may be a
lack of dignity or a lack of control
just make the prospect unbearable going
forward
yeah and just one more question to to
you
um either baroness Mitra or Lord
Faulkner
um six months of a diet from a diagnosis
to uh of a prognosis of death
um is that with or without treatment
because one of our kind of discoveries
in Oregon was that somebody could have a
prognosis of six months without
treatment however with medical
intervention they could have equality of
life we met somebody who'd lived 23
years
I mean I mean six months it is in the in
the context of what's Happening then if
I'm not taking treatment and I've only
got six months to live then that's six
months if for example I've got treatment
I mean there's lots and lots of
illnesses which if you're treating for
them you can last forever and ever and
if you're taking the treatment and happy
with that then you've got an indefinite
amount of time to live it's upon it you
have to look at the circumstances of the
individual patient
as I said before people are not then
going to take get hold of and take the
medicine until right towards the end of
their lives by which time things are
very very clear and and and and and and
doctors and everybody around the patient
will be very clear about what is going
to happen can I take an example like I
mean take the anorexic example somebody
who is not eating and as you get as it
goes on their life expectancy gets less
and less because they become weaker and
weaker
those circumstances under the bill that
Molly and myself the separate bills will
be introduced I would have thought it
was inconceivable that a high court
judge would say it's okay in those
circumstances that's why you have high
court judge but you need a timing
sorry elores feels tempted to say what
the high court judge would do no
okay I
don't know
they would and
that wouldn't ever go to court
um a a young a young woman with severe
anorexia nervosa May well have a very
poor prognosis but if she does come out
the other side it's usually women
sometimes men then they can go on to
have a completely full life yep I agree
I wanted to come on to the issue of
withdraw of food
fluid because clearly that doesn't lend
itself to a good death for people could
you just talk through your experience
about the implications of that because
that is currently legal for the
withdrawal a patient to choose for the
withdrawal of food and fluid right
within within the clinical context it's
really extremely rare for patients to
decide that they don't want food and
fluid because that is basic care
um they must still have all care even if
they've refused all treatment
if I can go back to motor neurone
disease where patients may decide they
no longer want to continue with for
instance supported ventilation they
withdraw their consent and they are
supported and looked after as they die
they're dying of their motor neurone
disease that they would have died of
months or weeks previously in terms of
fluids
um I actually think that probably the
medical profession have been over
cautious about putting up for example
subcutaneous fluids on patients at home
just to keep them comfortable it's
really easy to do
and patients can can have fluids even if
they don't want to eat it is up to the
patient and you must discuss all these
things with the patient quite openly and
listen to what their concerns are and
also ask them if there are other things
that they would want to do in their time
and are not able to do and that
conversation about where are you going I
had a patient who wanted to go to
dignity he was absolutely adamant it's
just he had pain and needed pain control
for the journey in that conversation
when I asked him is there anything else
you've always wanted to do and prompted
him he then told me that he'd actually
always wanted to go on a cruise well I'm
no travel agent but we arranged for him
to go on a cruise with his wife when he
came back weeks later he said it had a
wonderful time I thought he now would
want to go to dignitas his comment was
no I actually want to go on another
Cruise so he went on three cruises and
then in the middle of winter he went to
portcall Beach and then he he died
subsequently it was very very cold out
on Paul's Court
um but actually you need to know what
patients really want and what's
motivating them and you need to
understand their fears and listening is
the core skill of everybody in terms of
understanding what needs to happen and
in at the going back to the ethical
dilemma it is about listening to what
people want and weighing in the balance
harms against the benefits with the
patient and listening to what they want
and detecting pressures on them because
we mustn't forget about coercive
pressures and we mustn't forget about
abuse the the data is that about one in
five people over 65 in the UK have been
affected by abuse
that data from all over the world is
borne out sadly elder abuse is really
Rife it is not picked up by the
clinicians it's only picked up by the
clinicians when it's physical abuse but
most is financial emotional neglect and
so on and those are precious on people
and I've had patients who when they have
revealed that they were being abused
their requirements for analgesia dropped
dramatically because actually we were
able to support them and sort out the
problems that they had
just one more question that surrounds
these difficult deaths as I I've
categorized them and
um
how advanced is medicine for dealing
with every scenario of a difficult death
and how could that be dealt with under
palliative care to ensure that somebody
didn't have such address okay
thank you for asking that because I
think it's really important to be clear
that nothing in medicine is a hundred
percent if you if you have meningitis
you'll be given antibiotics but they it
isn't 100 that they will work nothing is
100 however access to high quality
specialist palliative care is still
inadequate around the country we're
getting there we're more advanced than
any of these other countries it's worth
remembering that L sport who took the
law through in the Netherlands went on
to say and I can actually
quote her she said in the Netherlands we
first listened to the political and
societal demand in favor of euthanasia
obviously this was not in the proper
order
and it's only just recently that the
Netherlands are developing specialist
palliative care as a discipline the
training that people have in this
country is much greater than in any of
these other countries and I think it is
a you have to look at the balance how
safe is safe enough and the evidence
from the other countries is that there
will be some people who die when
actually their death was based on the
wrong information the information they
had in making that choice was
misinformation and that's the problem
and I think you also have to look at
what is the acceptable number of
unacceptable deaths through error and
decide that if you're making a law that
allows doctors
or anybody else to give lethal drugs to
a patient at their request
because it is a balance of harms and we
have a duty to the most vulnerable in
society not only to the most vocal in
society
Rachel you are you concluded excellent
pondering there um okay Paul blomfield
thanks sure
um
parents Holdings you talk to I'm sure
we'd all agree them we need to have more
mature conversations about death
would you accept
that as part of those conversations we
would have to recognize
that even the best palliative care
can't provide a good death for everybody
as hospice UK have suggested
I think I think the difficulty there's a
real difficulty because I think there's
an awful lot of this is to do with fear
and a fear
um
throughout the system on both sides
patient and you know clinicians
um and um
I'm sorry but my mind is full of the
previous conversation about motor
neurone disease and dignity and I feel
that that you know that I should just
say that I have a family member with
motor neuron disease at the moment
and um but what's really interesting
about it is that in my family we're not
really afraid of what you describe as a
loss of dignity and that's because
um of 17 years ago my daughter
was stabbed and paralyzed and has a high
level spinal injury she didn't speak for
many many months
um her life it could not be more
dignified
okay
she is still paralyzed but she lives a
full life She's Not Afraid and in our
family we're not afraid of disability
because we've actually met it and lived
with it and I've worked my life so
imaginary disease doesn't have the fear
attract the fear that it does in some
other people who are less familiar
there's no loss of dignity in any of the
things which have been described I think
it's fear which is behind it and fear
causes pain and I think that's what's
it's not just a physical issue it's
partly a psychological issue and being
able to sit and listen to people and
hear what their fears are changes things
I sat with my daughter's mother-in-law
when she was dying um 18 months ago she
was afraid she was afraid of all sorts
of things she was afraid of taking pain
relief
but when she'd had the pain relief
was able to just settle and reflect on
her life and spend time with her family
the pain relief worked and yet she had
one of those diagnoses that everybody
said it's the most terrible death she
didn't have a terrible death she had a
beautiful death at home
and I think it's those psychological
issues which are actually really really
fundamental to our understanding about
death and talking about it the number of
times that somebody will ring me up and
say my mother's dying she's in pain
she's in hospital it's terrible and I
said has anybody talked to her about
palliative care and the fact that she's
dying is what everybody's tiptoeing
around the subject and it's always well
nobody likes to mention it nobody likes
to mention it as soon as it's mentioned
as soon as the the the palliative care
physician or clinician is invited to
come in things change and it's the lack
of addressing the issue doctors are not
comfortable with saying to their patient
you are dying how can we help you
that's that's the difficulty
I'm I'm really very sorry to hear about
your daughter
but but that wasn't my question yes my
question was
can in hospice UK has Lord Faulkner has
indicated have said in their view that
even the very best care can't avert a
bad death for some people do you accept
that
is going to be true but I don't think
it's as widespread as people think and I
think the point about it is simply and
that's why I was talking about the
psychological because I think the
psychological is actually under
underneath an awful lot of this
um
much for that I think accepting that
that is
in fact the case
um I wonder if I could just explore with
you
[Music]
um
the consequences of the current
law
um
because we're often in this debate focus
on
change but actually the current law has
implications for people
um I mean baroness Finley you talked
about the ons
um
study which showed that
people with terminal illness are twice
as likely to take their own lives let me
finish my question
um and this has to make that's around
650 people a year
they are
lonely and often very difficult deaths
my father was one of them
and he didn't as you suggested and make
that decision at the point of diagnosis
he actually took that decision
shortly after he'd sat down with
macmillan's nurse
and
had been through what is last
months might look like
so I guess my question is
are you satisfied that the current legal
settlement has no negative consequences
for individuals who take those decisions
and indeed for their families
and
can I say first of all a suicide is a
devastating event for anybody as is even
an attempted suicide because it raises
all kinds of questions in those Left
Behind which are particularly difficult
and thank you for speaking openly
because I think it's important that we
know where people come from
in terms of
I'm back to the question of balance
sadly and and I say sadly there will
always be some people
for whom carrying on is not tolerable
but the rate of other suicides as well
in the country
um is is not lowered the rate of suicide
amongst people who are dying is not
lowered by having this change in the law
which is why the suicide data from
countries that have changed the law
becomes important
in and I think sadly within our lives we
will not meet the needs of every single
person in the population but I'd go back
to that question that you have to ask is
how safe is safe enough if you change
the law you talked about 650 suicides a
year if you look at the data even if we
took the Oregon figures which are meant
to be the lowest Emily Jackson who has
been known to be a supporter of a change
in the law gave a lecture a couple of
weeks ago and her estimate is that
there'd be 5 800 assisted suicides in
the UK with the Oregon figures if we
look at the figures from Canada or the
Netherlands there'd be probably tenfold
that and then you have to look at what
do you want your clinical staff to do do
you want your clinical staff to be
looking after patients who are dying and
working to relieve their distress or are
you going to take them away from that in
order to process assisted dying assisted
suicide requests and the data from
Australia suggests that it takes 60
hours of clinical time now we know that
we have an enormous short form of
clinicians in this country already and
you're going to take thousands of
full-time equivalent hours
out of The Clinical Services if you put
this as a clinical Duty by changing the
law so I'm back to that question of
balance you take people away from
Clinical care to assist suicide you
decrease the number of people who are
there to look after people who are
distressed and work to relieve their
distress and I don't think anyone should
underestimate the shortfall in
clinicians that we have in this country
in with with the courageous respect that
wasn't my question my question was do
you think there are any
difficult consequences from the existing
law
that there are I would say there are
difficult consequences from every law
that we have for some people so to say
no would be
very naive actually there will be some
people who want to go to Switzerland to
kill themselves but we have people who
go abroad for all kinds of activities we
don't police those activities of them
going abroad we have laws in our country
about how we behave towards our citizens
and on balance and back to that I do
think that on balance our law is safer
than the evidence from countries that
have changed the law
in that context
um you've acknowledged obviously that
people go to Switzerland and other
people
take their own decisions to to take
difficult deaths
I think the current law provides any the
debate around a change in the law is
about safeguards yes
and about the worries about coercion is
a factor
what are the safeguards in the current
law
um how do we know that people going to
Switzerland haven't been coerced well
the the director part that's why the
director of public prosecution's
guidance is that and why our law was
changed that you don't prosecute people
who take their own life because that
would have been completely inhumane but
the dangers are of coercion the dangers
are of pressure and of the director
public prosecutions cases I think some
have I can't recall the exact number but
I can try and get them for you if you
want that of who have preceded to
prosecution because there was
certainly malintent behind the
persuasion but when you look in
countries where the law has changed uh
that doesn't seem to go go away either
you don't remove the ability for
families to coerce somebody the Canadian
experiences of patients being offered
to have lethal drugs we know of the
actually to who was offered euthanasia
rather than a ramp for her wheelchair
you would agree that the there are no
safeguards in our existing law
um and the risk of coercion
is a is a factor that needs to be taken
account of either under a new legal
settlement on assisted dying or indeed
under a current situation I think the
safeguards in our current system are
greater
than the proposals that we've seen on
the table
the bill that baroness mitcha put
forward we put down amendments to
uh we said quite openly that we were
wanting to tighten us the so-called
safeguards because we didn't think that
they were verifiable
actually nobody from the campaign
scientists come to discuss any of those
amendments with us there's been an
accusation that they were vexatious they
were not they were to try to make it
safer in the event of that legislation
passing and I think you have to be aware
that if you're going to have safeguards
there must be things that are verifiable
and the proposals that we've seen have
not had verifiable safeguards in them
but there are no safeguards in the
existing system
well this
is the way that the law has changed in
other countries because that's the basis
I know it wasn't your question but I do
think you have to look at the evidence
nowhere is there any monitoring of the
consultation itself in which the
discussion happens over assisted suicide
or euthanasia that was not a proposal in
any of the legislation either that those
consultations will be monitored the
suggestion of a second doctor had
nothing about the relationship between
the two nor the amount they're involved
so if you're going to have safeguards
there must be ones that you can verify
that you can go back and audit
afterwards I'll leave it there but
obviously my question was about
safeguards under the existing system and
the sort of safeguards that you describe
simply don't exist in our current legal
settlement but thank you
thank you Paul James Morris
um I'm assuming that even if we were to
change the law on the basis of what Lord
Falkland said that we'd still have the
need for a mental capacity assessment
for the individual so I wanted to ask
um baroness Hollins whether you thought
that that would put pressure on our
current definition of what mental
capacity is or what the implications
would be
um if any
it's a it's such a complicated area I
sat on the post legislative scrutiny
committee with the mental capacity act
and
um
there were just huge difficulties with
it as it stands at the moment with in
that very few uh clinicians really seem
to understand how to assess capacity
it's still not
um fully understood implemented and I
think it will confuse or would confuse
the situation further at the moment it
doesn't
um extend decisions about an assisted
death
um do you think do you think they meant
that the law and around mental capacity
would need to be updated to reflect any
changes that came along with the new law
um
I think it well it's it's I think it
would but I think it's also just so big
it's been found to be such a complicated
area I mean there's a big discussion
about whether we should have uh you know
a combined mental capacity and mental
health act to try to sort of address
some of these issues
um it's it would be a very lengthy
process to try to get to to get to the
uh to something which is is kind of
um in any way satisfactory but I think
just the difficulties even of assessing
capacity from for some quite simple
decisions
um and not well managed within our
within our with our within our system
um it's it's a very interesting question
and a very interesting area to explore
but it's it's it's not something that
has a simple answer I'm afraid well do
you do you consider there to be impacts
on mental capacity law as a result of
the changes that you may propose
the bills that have been proposed to say
that the person who decides to have an
assisted death has to have the capacity
to make that decision
and that's all the bill says
the mental capacity act says in my view
correctly indetermining whether
somebody's got mental capacity you've
got to have regard to what the sort of
decision is it's hard to imagine a more
serious decision than whether or not you
should take your own life that is a
factual decision that both doctors in
some circumstances in the courts and
other circumstances are used to
addressing it's a very serious decision
but it's one that they are capable of
taking speak myself I don't think there
will be any need for a change in the law
because the question is looking at this
particular person is he or she in a
state where she can make he or she can
make the decision as to whether to take
their own life are they for example
affected by depression are they affected
by mental impairment that prevents it
but it's a factual question that it is
it is perfectly
possible for doctors and courts to make
and although I I note what Sheila says
honestly over quite a considerable
period of time
particularly judges have been capable of
doing that
hypothetical perhaps in the in the
situation that you described about a
girl suffering from severe anorexia do
you think hypothetically
she would be deemed to have capacity to
make a decision to end her own life
I think the dangerous it depends on the
ability of the clinicians taking the
assessment making the assessment I had
the privilege of chairing the mental
capacity for him for six years and I
have to say it was really worrying to
see the inability of clinicians to
really assess capacity particularly
fluctuating capacity another group of
patients where there is a real worry is
where there's frontal lobe involvement
in the brain where they can appear as if
they're complete as if they have
capacity but actually they cannot
understand the implications of their
decision for themselves and others and
only last week
I came across a clinical case of
somebody who in ICU who appeared to have
complete capacity to stop treatment by
chance his girlfriend arrived and it I
won't go into the details of it because
it's a long story but he then decided to
marry her
and afterwards he had absolutely no
recall whatsoever of any of the
conversations that had taken place where
he said he didn't want to be treated but
at the time his clinicians not just one
but three of them thought that he was
absolutely crystal clear that he wanted
to stop treatment and would have stopped
his ventilation if it wasn't a chance
arrival of his girlfriend which
indicates that the the the the bills are
the most safeguarded route because what
what illora is talking about there quite
rightly is where people decide maybe on
backgrounds to withdraw treatment
where there'll be no safeguards
whatsoever well this
the point is that when you're assessing
capacity
you have to go back and look again and
think again the clinicians had a tiny
element of Doubt which is why they
didn't just act there and then but
decided to wait to see what happened
with him even though he appeared to have
capacity and that is a big problem and
it's a big problem in Care Homes as well
where you've got people who've got
frontal lobe involvement
Thanks James I'm I'm conscious we are
running behind time but this is such
important stuff and we will still
attempt to finish
on time
um Paula Hamilton finally in this
section right and good morning and
ladies and gentlemen my question is
geared at baroness Finley baroness you
could have had the question but
unfortunately I've picked baroness
Finley and if you don't mind baroness
meet you
it's a really simple question I'm about
families and
um I had the I had the I read a report
that was published by MacMillan in 2017.
it was called No Regrets
the report talked about death it also
talked about
um that people treated death with a
little bit of a taboo so we don't talk
about it enough it also stated that 64
of people
um just don't talk about death at all
till it's upon them so my question to to
you both are
patience in their family if they're
giving enough opportunity and support
are they given enough opportunity and
support to discuss death and dying
before it gets to the stage where people
feel isolated they feel they can they
feel they have no support and then they
take decisions like committing suicide
so that's my question if I can put sit
simply no they don't have enough
opportunity even clinicians are slow to
refer patients to palliative care early
because they're frightened of having
that conversation to say that the
prognosis is not good even though we've
moved a lot from where we were
previously
the biggest biggest group are children
you've already heard that every class
has on average one child who's lost to
parent or sibling and two other children
who've been bereaved as somebody close
to them and yet in schools very few
teachers I think it's a way below half
have got any training in managing
bereaved children we don't talk about
deaf and dying during covid it really
came to the fore as people suddenly
became aware of the threat of death from
kovid and what was happening and the
other problem is even when people are
bereaved people don't talk openly and
just let them talk about the person
who's died so I'm afraid no and yet
death is going to hit everybody
nobody can escape the fact that we will
all die one day and we as a society need
to decide how do we provide that support
and help people prepare
um thank you
um it appears that the doctors are the
problem
um Marie Curie showed that about 65
percent of dying people were able to
talk to their friends and family about
dying about their concerns and so forth
but a yougov uh study revealed that only
16 percent of dying people had had a
discussion with their doctor about what
was going to happen as their condition
worsened and this is a very very serious
issue for people that they just feel
they cannot talk to their doctor about
their death and dying and we know from
the jurisdictions that have assisted
dying that doctors are then much more
comfortable about talking with their
patients about dying about pain control
about hospice care and so on it opens up
the relationship and the conversations
between patients and their doctors if
the doctor knows that if you know things
become unbearable for the patient they
can actually help them right the way
through at the moment at the point of
greatest greatest need for the patient
the patient cannot cope anymore the top
doctor is unable to help and that
interferes with a doctor's feeling that
they can actually have those well my
last point and I'll open it up I
actually would be really interested to
see what Lord Faulkner said
if you were going to give advice going
forward what would that advice be around
educating people talking about things a
lot earlier about this taboo that you've
talked about so we don't get to the
stage where all people want to do is end
it all and Lord fought me I'd like to
hear what you've got to say on that I
mean I
all three of the previous speakers have
indicated people don't there's not
enough discussion about one's death
because as Laura says we're all going to
die you need to be much more open about
what are the prospects of how one dies
that will have the effect I suspect of
reducing much of the fear that is
associated with death and the longer one
has the opportunity to talk about death
to clinicians that might help them the
better one will be equipped to do it
even if you have these conversations for
very many people the prospect of the
disability the pain the lack of control
and the lack of dignity that comes
because because not everybody is able to
cope as Sheila's family have with the
lack of dignity that comes from Death or
the lack of control because different
people have different levels of
resilience and for some people even with
the best help in the world the idea of
going through a period where they're
completely disabled the idea of going
through a period they're dependent upon
those who love them just unbearable
and so you need to have that discussion
what can you cope with because people's
levels are so different
so I was going to stop there but what
you've said really interests me because
where my parents come from from the day
you're born you're hearing about death
you'll be living in a house with a
grandmother that's probably on a journey
or someone in the family so
what would your point be about perhaps
in England we've got this stiff upper
lip in the UK in this part of the world
and we don't talk about it it's like a
need to know basis perhaps doing things
like talking about death at an earlier
stage do you think that would be more
helpful and would help people to get to
the point when they come to the last
stages of their life you don't get that
fear that you so highlighted earlier on
and I'll ask baroness Islands to what do
you think about the point I've just made
and then I'm done absolutely and it's
just such a taboo and we have to learn
how to talk through the taboo and and
that includes death but it also includes
what you're calling dignity but I I
think the dignity
um the dignity comes in part from the
comfort of of sharing fear of
understanding of seeing of participating
of engaging of experiencing grief of
understanding that this is part of the
life cycle I I I I've just
you know and I'm
yeah I just I just think let's open the
subject up let's just talk about it
let's talk about it that's a good way to
end it thank you
very good for all that okay um baroness
Finley baroness Hollins baroness meets
her and Lord Faulkner thank you so much
for your time and your honesty and
opening our inquiry session uh so
frankly we're going to take a very very
short break when we change our panel and
bring somebody in online thank you very
much order order thank you thank you
thank you for inviting
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suicide
um we've obviously just heard from four
Piers of the realm and now we have a
second panel so we have appearing
remotely Dr Naomi Richards who's a
senior lecturer in social science and
director of the Glasgow end of life
studies group at the University of
Glasgow
um Naomi specializes in death and dying
aging and old age we have in the room Dr
Alexandra mullet who's a senior lecturer
in healthcare law and co-director at the
center for social ethics and policy at
the University of Manchester
um I think in 2021 Alex was one of the
legal experts to the government of
Jersey citizens jury on assisted dying
that's very interesting to us and
Professor Nancy Preston who is the
professor of supportive and palliative
care at the University of Lancaster
um professor professor has a strong
interest in how people make decisions
about their future care she's conducted
research about Adas in the U.S
Switzerland and the Netherlands as well
as experiencing
exploring the experiences of British
families following an assisted death
overseas so a really interesting panel
um we think sorry we're a bit late
starting but thank you very much for
your patience and for your time we're
going to start with Chris Green yes Jim
uh Dr uh I'm just wondering uh with the
deliberations over the Jersey citizens
jewelry there must have been a bit of a
discussion about the scope in terms of
the sister diocese's suicide the scope
of people who might be included on that
could you just briefly highlight how
that conversation went
so the jewelry were given quite a sort
of broad flexible remit in terms of
firstly deciding whether in principle
assisted dying or to be legalized in
Jersey and then subsequently
to decide the sort of parameters of that
um and the majority of the jewelry
decided that both physician-assisted
suicide and euthanasia should be legal
and this should be available for
terminally ill people and people
suffering unbearably
okay so it's slightly broader than other
errors but in terms of that uh until
illness for example would there be a
kind of six month your prognosis has to
be a six-month prognosis so that kind of
constraint as well what was the
discussion in terms of
um for example in Belgium as I pointed
out earlier uh children can also be
included in the remit was there any
discussion over that no um no there
wasn't I mean the the jewelry heard many
hours of evidence from a range of
experts including from Europe and so
they were made aware of the approach in
Belgium but they voted to limit
eligibility to adults and in terms of
the criteria for adults were the groups
participating in the Citizen's jury who
perhaps were excluded from that option
perhaps the legislation as
supported or the approach as supported
were there any groups that would have
been excluded from the conclusions that
were drawn in terms of who wouldn't be
eligible in terms of adults well there
was a capacity requirement
so
um in in a similar way to the way that
other jurisdictions with permissive
regimes have a requirement of capacity
and that was also so that sounds to me
uh as though it's quite a broad quite an
open approach perhaps a broader than
most jurisdictions around the world and
people were going into that very
consciously perhaps thinking that it's
significantly broader perhaps than
Oregon and other places certainly and
the approach that the jury voted for is
certainly more more broad than Oregon
and it's it's really similar to the
approaches in the Netherlands and Canada
so other than perhaps going down the uh
under 18 route there wouldn't be such a
question from the evidence you saw over
that kind of uh
moving uh or expanding the range of
people included
well that wasn't something that the jury
were asked
so they were limited to the the
questions about whether they thought in
principle it should be lawful and if so
who foreign children were not part of
that that conversation thank you
okay thank you Paul Bristow thank you
chair
um first question to Professor Nancy
Preston from Lancaster University my old
University so um welcome
um do you think there's enough data
available about access to and the
provision of palliative care and end of
Life Care in England and Wales
we've got
there won't be enough until
Health Service and it's got full funding
I mean 75 funded from tombow tombola's
and things like that
what we have got in the UK is much
greater access for more people with
different conditions so I do a lot of
work in Europe it's mainly still for
people with cancer whereas in the UK
it's expanded to you know people with
COPD heart failure motor neurone disease
it's a much broader church although
people most commonly think of it as for
people with cancer but we're having to
develop Services largely for those
people in the community funded outside
of the Health Service which limits its
reach how do you feel if we if we had a
a much more focused and one and and
Universal palliative care system how do
you think that would influence the
debate around assisted dying resourcing
I think if you look at the origin case
in particular
um Linda ganzini who did a lot of the
work in the states looking at it she
used to refer to Oregon man and Oregon
man doesn't want to be a burden Oregon
man was hunting shooting fishing and
kind of wants to make his own choices
towards the end of life so these are
decisions people are making
regardless of the care they're going to
receive so it's not necessarily always
about poor provision of palliative care
it can be about people wanting control
and that's what you hear a lot in the
debate in the discussion sorry with
patients and their families
and how would you react to the evidence
we heard earlier about
um about burden and control
um because would you accept that there
is a
um would you accept that there's a
feeling that to be
um
how do I put this in the most dignified
way
um we heard evidence earlier from um
from people saying that those with
disabilities and those who had lost
control that their their life certainly
from baroness I think Finley
um was saying that
um they didn't feel like it was a burden
I mean everyone's experiences are
different
um do you feel there's a fear of that
burden that there's contagion that
people will begin to feel that they are
a burden or did not is that not weighed
by the evidence we've got no evidence to
support that but that that would happen
I think but just what we do commonly
here is about people wanting to remain
as independent for as long as they can I
guess the concern is
that could apply to people with
disabilities in other groups and then
they can feel disenfranchised in the
decisions they're making and then it
gets back to coercion and contral
there's nothing in our evidence to say
anything about that really okay
okay thanks Paul right Paul at Hamilton
oh thank you um good morning both could
I um start with yourself
um Professor Preston I asked the
question to the first panel and I'm
going to ask the question again I'm
hoping you were in the room at the time
but it was about
um the fact that um there is a taboo
around
um people talking about death and dying
it was around the fact that 64 of people
think that we don't talk about death
enough and the question I asked the
first panel and I'm really interested
because of all the brilliant work you've
done is
um our patients and their families
um given enough opportunity and support
to discuss death and dying
let's see if I give you an example of a
large study we did across Europe we had
1100 patients and we were talking about
Advanced Care planning so what's the
kind of care you would want to receive
at the end of your life and towards the
end of your life you may lose competency
so you need to have talked to someone
you need to share those decisions in
advance most of the people who came on
the study probably had a meeting
survival of 12 weeks this was a really
important conversation when the doctors
tried to introduce it half of the
patient said I don't want to go there in
a good place right now which meant they
hadn't had that conversation and then
half of the ones he said they did want
to the families said well actually
they're a really good place right now
so we're trying to train people to have
those conversations better we've got
free online resources and one of my
drivers I'm using is the ambulance
service because if we don't have those
conversations and it might feel like you
don't want to upset someone and it's not
a good time
the paramedic turns up and they're
facing a family they've never met before
having a really difficult conversation
in a very acute moment so we do need to
be better about it and we know that we
can make that better we did it during
covid in Care Homes and we trained up
the care home staff to have those
conversations and families and the
families responded incredibly positively
to it
thank you for that I'm I'm going to ask
you the next question but again I'm
gonna I'm gonna Focus the next question
on you because it's around
um doctors and the question is around
let me start by saying I have the
absolute pleasure myself in the
committee a number of us here have going
to Oregon and it really opened my eyes
to this subject but one thing that I
found out while we were there large
numbers of doctors didn't want to be
part of it and I think it was
highlighted earlier that only two
percent of the doctors from Oregon
actually wanted to take part in anything
around assisted dying now the question I
have is um how does the legislation of
assisted dying impact on care
practitioners so nurses doctors and
others and what support are they be
would they be given to take on this
massive role yeah and I think it depends
on jurisdiction so in the Netherlands
where we did research there the doctors
are very supported within the process
but even though they're very supported
it can be well one of the quotes we got
was it stressful killing somebody
um but that was somebody who carried on
doing that but they would maybe
sometimes some people feel okay with it
some people feel I can manage one or two
a year other people say I can't be
involved and they can't be involved
when we did research in Switzerland they
may not even feel able to say well there
is a right to die Association you can
talk to you might I might not be able to
have that conversation and so it there's
real gradients of their level of
involvement and the impact it can have
on them and the Swiss system I think we
don't really talk about a lot but it's
they promote it as almost a civil system
where it's been contracted out to the
right to die associations because like
in a lot of countries assisted dying
doesn't happen in hospitals it
predominantly happens in people's homes
and the Netherlands is scared and
hospices so the Swiss model is very much
that it's outside of the system of the
main Healthcare System with volunteer
doctors this is their sort of passion
and drive and so it's taken out of
mainstream Health which has removed some
of the pressure on the doctors within
the Health Service in Switzerland so do
you feel that this country is anywhere
near equipped to do anything like that
I don't know if doctors in this country
really know what it would feel like to
do it I don't think anybody does until
you're faced with it and as I said
there'll be in range of responses as to
whether they feel able and I think
Barrel has Finley mentioned in the BMA
report although there's a lot of support
for it and I think that's in part
reflects people thinking well maybe I
need it myself so but I don't think I
could do it myself
now could I bring you in and doctor is
it mullock yes yes oh fantastic
um
we've had as a committee we've had
evidence from all over the world
especially the ones that have been
highlighted uh Belgium Oregon
um there's one more oh Netherlands
um we've had information come to the
committee and express and they have
expressed concerns
um about this the association of
palliative medicine
um I've
have expressed concerns about people
reporting
um information around
um the issue of assisted dying and
medication and while while we were in
Oregon the thing that got to me was the
the reporting of things I'm not going to
say was a little bit slap Dash because I
I feel that's trivializing it but I felt
that
we could have had a narrow shipment and
they wouldn't have known because it's
just very database matter of fact after
it all happened and I'm not sure how
much of that was really checked so the
information is um do you feel the
quality of information
um reported from other jurisdictions
like Oregon Belgium Netherlands relating
to assisted suicide assisted dying
um is actually good enough
that's a really difficult question to
answer and I can't actually answer it
but I sort of
Point work of some
of something done
appraisals of the monitoring systems
that have been put in place
um
one example is Professor Penny Lewis
who's actually now a law commissioner
has done some work on this and her
assessment is actually that the
monitoring that that's carried out is is
actually quite robust and sound
particularly perhaps in the Netherlands
and if I remember correctly I think over
a sort of tenure period 111 examples of
possible breaches of the the Dutch
criteria were reported to prosecutors
that led to one prosecution and an
acquittal
it's really not possible because it
relies on honest reporting so you know
potentially
it's uh there are problems and flaws in
that approach but
like so many things it's really
difficult to assess how robust that that
monitoring is so thank you for that so
my final question chair with all the
research you've done around this area
what are your views do you think it is
possible you're smiling at me I like
that what do you think do you think it's
possible to get honest reporting on this
in this area I think it's challenging
and I think in the Netherlands I think
they have a very sort of clear Reporting
System but there is an anonymous survey
that is carried out I think it's every
other year or every year by the team at
Erasmus and they find that doctors
closer to the end of life are more
likely to use what they call palliative
sedation so uh you know a larger dose of
sedation rather than going through the
um Youth and agency legislation but it's
an anonymous survey it's difficult to
interpret and understand but it does but
it doesn't mean they're doing euthanasia
but they're reliant on going to large
doses of drugs to sedate people we're
doing a big study at the moment on
sedation across Europe and trying to
understand practice and within
palliative care is very much titrated
proportional according to the patient
need but what happens but more so in
maybe GP practices things like that it
can be used in different ways so that
would be outside of the current
legislation excellent point to stop
thank you chair absolutely brilliant
thank you ladies James Morris thank you
Joe
um one of the challenges that we have on
this inquiry is obviously this is a very
emotive subject which can polarize views
but it is in what is the nature of the
evidence base that this committee is
actually looking at because we make a
policy change needs to be on a robust
basis of evidence so I just was going to
ask each of you it's probably starting
with Dr Richards about about what you
thought the critical pieces of evidence
that this committee should be looking at
as it deliberates on this matter maybe
one critical piece of evidence that you
think is is absolutely Central to our
deliberations Dr Richards
um from what I've heard today you're
covering a lot of the big issues
um one critical piece of evidence
I suppose
thinking about the arguments for and
against that have been rehearsed in the
House of Commons and the House of Lords
for many decades now I suppose the big
piece of evidence is whether there's
abuse and whether vulnerable people are
coming within the scope of any
legislation in any jurisdiction so that
would be kind of the number one thing
for me I think and just on that point is
there do you think there's there's there
is
robust evidence about that particular
issue to do with abuse
does that exist as a body of evidence in
a coherent place
robust evidence that there is abuse
as Professor Preston has said today
already
um however it is
a hard thing to research as well I would
say
Dr Dr Malik what's the what's the
critical evidence
would be should be looking at if it was
persuaded to
change the law or look at this issue
differently to the current
regime I think probably the evidence
from Oregon which you obviously have
already
explored on your visit I think that's
really critical because the Oregon
approach
um is is the approach that's proposed
under the recent bills we're which is a
sort of quite restrictive approach
um where only terminal people are
eligible
and so if you compare the evidence
coming out of Oregon where the numbers
have remained quite low and there is no
evidence of abuse although there also
have been reports of perhaps some worry
worrying examples of people with with
depression who are not adequately
assessed compared to the evidence coming
out of the Netherlands which has a much
more permissive approach where the
numbers of people choosing to die by
euthanasia have have grown quite a lot
and I think it's about four percent of
everyone who dies in The Netherlands
dies by assisted dying
um we'll just ask you one question and
sorry to interrupt about Oregon when we
were in Oregon a claim was made that the
introduction of assisted dying had quote
improved palliative care in in Oregon do
you have any perspective on that or
whether you think that's a credible
claim well I think it's certainly
credible because because I mean in this
in a sense although they are very very
sort of intertwined they're also
separate issues and if a jurisdiction
makes a determined effort to improve
palliative care
um then I think that it's perfectly
possible for palliative care to improve
at the same time as legalizing some form
of assisted dying
vice president or do you think of the
critical evidence basis committee should
be considering
parliamentarians to come
but if you do were to change the law I
would really recommend you look at the
impact on healthcare workers and the
families and ensure that they are looked
after as well because the debate often
is very focused on the patient and the
patient right and I think you know we
need to make sure everybody involved in
this is supported and looked after
Bloomfield next
uh very much chair
um I think we established wherever you
are in this discussion in the first
session
um that everybody wants to see the very
best palliative care
but even the best palliative care can't
avoid a bad death for some people
would you agree with that and let me
start with Dr Richards
um well uh yes I would agree with that
um and it depends how you define what a
bad death is because as was discussed in
the previous session
um this isn't just about pain and
symptom management
um this is about
autonomy and it's about dependency and
it's about people's identity because
um how people die
um is seen to sometimes represent
something about who they are to say
something about who they are so I think
it's really important that we don't just
think it's about pain and symptom
management although it is in some cases
so a bad death for some people is not
dying on their own terms
um
thanks very much I don't know whether
Professor Preston you'd like to add to
that at all
I mean I think if we as Naomi said it
was talking about physical symptoms I
think you can on the whole
try and treat those and it is through
sedation so it does mean that you would
be losing Consciousness early in the
similar way maybe you would be having an
assisted death early but I think I think
home is absolutely right for some people
it's not about that it's about
continents it's about Mobility it's
about being able to make decisions for
yourself and that's you know for the
classic example would be someone with
say spinal cord compression and they
know what is what is going to happen in
the future and they think I don't want
to be like that and it could take a long
time before they died but that's not
where they want to be so I think it's a
it's a mixture of those a lot of the
stuff we can manage with sedation but
how people feel about themselves is is
different
thanks
um
obviously the debates
um that's taking place in various
jurisdictions has kind of landed with
two roots and one is about assisted
dying laws for those with terminal
illness
other countries have gone further in
relation to unbearable suffering
there's an argument that if we change
the law
in relation to terminal illness which is
where the debate is in this country
there's an inevitability of a slippery
slope into widening the law is there any
evidence of that from jurisdictions
which have taken the route of
um terminal illness
um Dr mullet
um no I don't think there is
um Oregon
um has had the same approach that hasn't
expanded for
um you know
quite a long time now I think
um there is there is evidence that if
you begin with an approach that allows
it for unbearable suffering caused by a
severe physical condition
then it's quite hard to maintain a sort
of intellectually
convincing or clinical distinction
between a physical illness that causes
unbearable suffering and a psychiatric
illness that causes unbearable suffering
but I think that that problem is removed
if you start if you if you have an
approach of terminal illness because
then it becomes about allowing people to
control
um an imminent death rather than cutting
many years off their lives
um I don't know whether Dr Richards you
have any views on that issue
yes I would agree with Dr Malik that
there is no inevitable expansion as we
can see from
the Oregon model which is the modeling
across states of the US
it's yet to be seen what will happen in
Australia New Zealand
and whether they will expand I think
um
it's also a question of how we frame
this expansion and whether we see you
know the population are perhaps deciding
that
um
you know they may legalize for a certain
group a certain category of person and
they may there may be widespread support
for that and then other people with
other kinds of
um illnesses suffering
um also want to have access to that type
that mode of dying and so
um it's not the the expansion is because
it's publicly demanded
um and the other reason why you might
have changes of criteria is because
they've seen from practical experience
they've seen what works and what doesn't
work and you know they're tweaking their
system it's not necessarily a slippery
to be categorized as a sort of a
negative slippery slope so that's just
my addition I would like to say
something else about the previous
question is that allowed yes of course
sorry
um just with a time to think
um I think this issue of like bad deaths
and suffering at the end of life is is
extremely important and in the previous
session there was a lot of discussion
about a case study of anorexia which is
really not what we're talking about here
there's 600 000 people that die annually
in this country we're talking about the
meaning of dying and that's really
important that we stay focused
um
I think there's a lack of knowledge
about how many people what and what
suffering entails at the end of life I
just think we have a kind of absence of
of knowledge and palliative care
professionals um deal with people who
are at the end of life in their
day-to-day practice and they they see
that and experience that and they they
help people um with their suffering
um but they you know that we have to ask
if they are
um
professionally inclined to sort of
to look at the extent of suffering
um if it's going to reflect badly on
there uh what they can offer uh patients
or what is out with what they can offer
their patients
um I I just as a researcher I feel that
there is a real lack of evidence about
the extent of suffering at the end of
life which feels uh which leaves a void
so um for example dignity in dying you
know that sort of that one of their
campaign angles is to say that there is
all this unmitigated suffering
um and then you get palliative care
organization saying it's not true and
honestly
um we don't know
um and I do think this is quite
important actually
um because it's it's not right to say
that
um
you know people don't need to fear dying
you know we can say it but maybe they do
if we don't have the evidence then maybe
they do need to be a dying so I just
wanted to make that point thanks okay
thanks very much last very nice question
uh to Dr Malik which is
um
from your experience of being involved
in the citizens jury process in Jersey
do you think that's a a helpful way of
engaging in this debate and did it did
you do you think it's a good process in
terms of taking things forward I do
think it's a very good process and a
really good way to you know
have Democratic participation
I think if if you're going to have a
citizen's Joy or indeed a referendum you
can almost be sure that they will vote
to legalize assisted dying we've seen
that I mean I think the results are very
soon to be out in France from their
citizens jewelry but early the Early
vote suggested that I think it was
something like 75 percent were in favor
of it that's what happened in Jersey in
New Zealand the referendum was I think
65 of the population were in favor of
um physician-assisted suicide for the
terminally ill so
if if if you know you accept that that's
almost certainly going to be the result
and you're you know prepared to
um go forward on that basis then I think
it is very useful
at Rachel maskel next
thank you I think what's come out today
is the importance of having information
to make informed choices and
um
but there are things that we don't talk
about and we don't gather information
about and therefore those choices are
all the more difficult and I think we've
already heard about the reluctance of
talking about death
um I think there's another area of taboo
and it certainly came out in the Oregon
day to around dignity and talking about
continents as being an issue whereas
many many people have to live with
incontinence in fact far more people
than we probably realized do and that
shouldn't be a an issue where people are
a a fearful of however in gathering
evidence it does seem that we have got
um a shortfall in in evidence that could
be helpful in decision making and I'm
I'm therefore quite interested in
digging into some of this so um first of
all Dr Richards bearing mind your
specialty at looking around older people
as well as
um
others um in the light that we heard in
the earlier session that one in five one
and six experience elder abuse what is
the
um evidence around people that have
sought say to go to Switzerland
um from the UK or people that are
requesting uh assisted suicide assist
death that have been coerced or
um have as a result of perhaps emotional
Financial other forms of abuse
so the evidence for people going to
Switzerland yeah of as an example yeah
yes uh
there is none
but they have been coerced
okay no there is none is that evidence
actually gathered as to the reasons why
and is that explored
um well there's been
um interviews with researchers with
relatives who uh and friends who return
um
uh there's been interviewed by police
before the dpb changed its Guidance the
um there was evident uh the the
relatives accompaniers were interviewed
by police
um so I think there has been some
scrutiny
um
and
there's no evidence
that we know of
okay and that's my big concern is about
evidence that we know of and being able
to drill down into are we asking the
right questions around this to protect
the most vulnerable
yeah I
idea that someone sort of I mean it's
quite a tricky process to get to
Switzerland
um and you know the right to die
organizations have their own
it's not just a free-for-all over there
it's a regulated process over there
so you've got all of the barriers with
traveling and the huge bureaucratic
barriers of applying from the UK uh then
sort of going there and then
bureaucratic barriers administrative
barriers procedural barriers at the
other end so I mean it would take a
seriously committed person
um who was trying to coerce a relative
it's
I mean this is really not the question
for me it would be much more about what
happens when it's lawful in your own
country rather than
well well clearly that how you find the
the legislation could well depend on a
kind of other experiences to know about
that that process
yep please do we've done interviews with
people who've from dignitas largely have
gone to Switzerland and and name is
right that you have to be very
determined to do that I don't think
there's any evidence of coercion with
them but in Switzerland again most
people is and it's their own choice it's
a very private decision it's very quiet
but we've had cases where not many very
few but where the family introduced the
idea and another case where um the the
um the treating physician had prescribed
and was happy to prescribe but felt the
patient then lacked competency so
couldn't have the drugs and the right to
die Association was going forward and
she stopped the procedure so I think you
know you I think as we've said is any
system possible to have every Safeguard
in place I think that's it's going to be
very challenging no matter what but you
are always going to get some cases
aren't you
thank you um for that could I also ask
about the quality of death as well and
what evidence there is
um on the number of deaths where people
have not
had
what I'm classifying as difficult deaths
where people have either been in pain at
the end of death or had a a very
uncomfortable death do we know what data
is on the numbers that we're talking
about though
that's not an area of my research to
look at does anyone hold that
information either no okay
okay and
um finally I just want to ask about the
scrutiny of the data in different
jurisdictions as well and one of the
things that I think concerned many of us
when in Oregon was some of the data that
was being held by their equivalent of
Department of Health
for instance
they didn't scrutinize the process of
people dying they didn't put it on on
death certificates the reason for death
and
the one of the statements that stuck in
my mind was when
um the civil servants said that it took
10 people took more than six hours to
die in Oregon when looking at the data
how you verify that how
the veracity of that data to ensure that
the right questions are being recorded
the right factors have been recorded in
order to analyze the real impact of
somebody's death experience in those
jurisdictions
in your research anything
okay so that shows further evidence of a
lack of information okay thank you
interesting in itself uh Lucy Allen
thank you
um I wonder if I could ask Dr Richard's
question about some of the research that
you've undertaken in jurisdictions where
assisted dying is lawful around
um
the coexistence of palliative care and
assisted dying how that how that works
together does it impact on the quality
of palliative care I think we heard
earlier that somehow it was detrimental
to palliative care can can you have
assisted dying and palliative care as
coexisting successfully
okay I'm glad you asked me this question
um I just want to say in response to the
previous question I I don't really look
at monitoring however I would say
there's a lot of jurisdictions that have
um you know past legislation which all
have different monitoring systems so if
you don't like the Oregon monetary
system then look to the Australian
monitoring system the
um the Lauren Victoria State Australia
is
um you know sort of considered the
strictest and most conservative in the
world and I'm sure they've got quite
developed monitoring systems so you know
that's uh something that is potentially
uh remediable so um in terms of the
question about the relationship so um
there's what we discovered was across
the jurisdictions that have legalized
there's very little
um research conducted
um I think we had about 16 studies um
that came into in our scoping review of
the literature and
um it's varied and contested across
different jurisdictions so um all the
way from Belgium where it's uh
considered sort of integral and
synergistic you know it was assisted
dying was kind of proposed by a
palliative care in that you know so they
were behind the legislation
um to you know places where it's um
Switzerland where again it's kind of the
Civil model so palliative care
professionals kind of don't aren't
really trained and how to deal with
requests
um to Oregon
where it's it's just quite variable you
know some in some institutions it works
alongside
um inside you know some institutions
conscientiously object so institutional
uh sort of conscientious objection in
that case
um but what's really interesting since
our
um scoping review in 2019 is that
um there's really interesting literature
coming through from Australia and from
Canada now and I think um while
palliative care organizations would like
um you know they still maintain it
palliative care organizations umbrella
organizations and jurisdictions that
have legalized will maintain their
opposition you know but this sort of
fundamental
um principle of to neither hasten nor
postpone death is kind of operating
principle
um but um
but yet it's sort of in many cases down
to the individual professionals to
decide whether they want to be involved
or not because it's a legal right and uh
so there's all of these kind of gray
areas and
um you know what uh palliative care
professionals specifically are having to
face is you know it's it's now
unavoidable that they will be asked by
their patients
um will you help me they've got a legal
right to ask and they've got a legal
duty to refer if they don't want to be
involved themselves so they're in an
interactional space now where they are
dealing with these requests but it's not
true to say that all palliative care
providers are conscientiously objecting
that's just not the case
um and sometimes you know it's it's it's
well it's causing deep reflection
negotiation and values responsibilities
and relationships and you know
self-examination of um you know maybe
why what motivates you to be in
palliative care in the first place but
some people um are embracing some people
are continuing to conscientiously object
it's a whole variety it's a spectrum
um so it's certainly
um not kind of this master Narrative of
incompatibility I was a meeting last
week
um the palliative care organization of
Canada was saying you know assisted
dying is an existential threat to
palliative care but it's just not the
case because palliative care continues
to operate and thrive in jurisdictions
where it's been legalized so it's just I
think if we've done that systematic
review of the literature and found you
know found a whole load of evidence then
um of sort of a panic and a sort of
deterioration of palliative care you
know the evidence would be there I think
um
you know so I'll stop there sorry that's
very helpful thank you very much
um Dr Malik I wonder if I could ask you
to comment on uh what Lord Faulkner told
us this morning about the current UK
England law on
um on this area he said it's it's a mess
I just wondered if with your legal
background whether you could comment on
your views on whether it is a mess yes I
do agree with Lord Faulkner
um
we I think you asked um Rachel before
about
um you know any evidence of coercion in
relation to people traveling to
Switzerland and there is no no evidence
but and what happens is the police
investigate following the return
um of the family member or friend who's
assisted the person who's died and and
there have been no prosecutions
um of course that doesn't mean they're
necessarily you know shouldn't have been
but insofar as a retrospective
investigation after the person who's
who's died is no longer here
um it's very difficult to actually
establish
um you know what motivated those
assisting Etc
um and so I think Lord Falconer was
right I think at the moment people feel
abandoned and very frightened they may
seek an assisted death abroad it's also
very expensive as well as this sort of
bureaucratic burden and the enormous
efforts to arrange that it costs I think
something along the lines of ten
thousand pounds so for many people they
just couldn't afford to take that that
route so they might otherwise
um you know choose to take their own
life by suicide in the jurisdiction
usually without helping circumstances
you know that that can be very very
difficult or distressing they might fail
um and so at the moment although you
could argue as I'm sure baroness Finlay
and baroness hollinswood that you know
people are prevented and so they're
saved by the ban in reality not
everybody is saved some people who are
vulnerable will go to Switzerland
others who have very vulnerable will die
by Suicide and then other people will
just simply you know have have to face
the natural death that that's coming for
them and in circumstances that that
might be you know very very difficult
um and in terms of from the medical
perspective
is there a lack of clarity if you're a
medical professional in terms of how you
respond to a patient who is requesting
assistance
well the General Medical Council has
produced guidance ethical guidance
to help clinicians to sort of
find the balance between talking to
patients and helping patients but not
encouraging or assisting them to towards
suicide so I think there is some
guidance there but it's incredibly
difficult for for healthcare
professionals to navigate that and also
very difficult I guess in terms of in
the palliative care context where a
person might be asking for
um you know hasten death
um and the fears that have come about in
recent years partly as a result I guess
of Harold Shipman
um but the the way that that area of of
care has been discretionized for example
with the Liverpool care pathway
um clinicians I think are probably very
worried about stepping over the line
thanks Lucy and then just just finally
from me um I I started the session today
by asking the four peers about their
lived experience and their personal
reasons and I I you know why do you care
so much I ask them
um obviously we many of us have
experienced deaths of people close close
to them and uh Professor person you've
spoken about the the least researched
and perhaps poorly understood area is is
how families experience death when
there's an assisted death or a hasten to
death is involved as opposed to
the normal course of of Life the normal
life course
um I just wondered what your reflect
obviously we've seen what you've sent us
in written evidence on this so I just
wondered if to the giving oral evidence
what your Reflections are on on that
Dynamic yeah and I think it's complex so
I think for the families
in some ways it's easier because they
know they can care for the person and
they know when the end date is going to
be so that it gives a bit of sort of a
it holds it
because often when you're waiting for
someone to die that can be quite
difficult because you don't know when
that's going to happen yes on the other
side uh there's the secrecy so normally
when you're going through something like
that a death in a home in a family
you'll be talking to everybody about it
you'd be sharing you'd be getting
support and because often people and I'm
talking particularly the Swiss data they
they don't want other people to have
these conversation with them so they
this is really hard work isn't it to
have these conversations and you you're
already in a quite a difficult place so
they hold it with one or two people so
the person is enabling and helping is
actually on their own quite badly in
this and at the end and after the death
there is secrecy into boost they may not
even tell the family what had happened
or they may tell the family and then the
rest of the family say why did no one
talk to me about this I feel
disenfranchised from it and I think
that's why we need to make sure that you
know we have a system where families are
involved and you know if I was in the UK
from dignitas would would rarely go to a
hospice for bereavement books I've been
very concerned about being investigated
yeah then just just finally maybe Dr
Miller You may wish to offer some
thoughts on this with respect to you
know when you're involved in Jersey in
the citizens jury I mean ultimately we
can talk about the the mechanics of this
we can talk about palliative care we can
talk about the drugs involved we can
talk about the family's responses but
there's a a Rubicon to be crossed here
one before we get into all of that which
is effectively the moral argument which
is do we believe that we should involve
ourselves in people's deaths
um and I just wondered what your
Reflections were on that being involved
in a in Jersey and any research that
you've done around that
[Music]
surprise very quickly if I was quite
surprised by the outcome of the citizens
jury in Jersey because they had you know
many many hours of very balanced
evidence looking at you know evidence
from campaigners evidence from
um religious groups evidence from
doctors they look they heard evidence
about the law in in lawful jurisdictions
and I was very surprised actually that
they that they decided that they wanted
to take quite a permissive liberal
approach
um based on you know the concerns that
they've heard my that's not that's not
my position I I feel quite worried about
what's happened in some places like
Canada and the Netherlands
um in terms of my research I did a PhD
on assisted dying as part of a project
on the impacts of the criminal law and
Healthcare ethics and practice
many years ago and that sort of started
um this this area being one of my areas
of research and so I've looked at sort
of Human Rights arguments and and the
key cases such as nicklinson
I've looked at
um conscientious objection and the way
that the law could protect Healthcare
professionals from being sort of
compelled and then more recently I've
looked at conceptions of vulnerability
to assistive dying
and so my I I think the approach taken
in Oregon New Zealand
um and Victoria is is probably
um provides a compromise between a sort
of liberal approach in which there are
dangers to people who are not
necessarily going to die soon anyway
um and so that's why I think it ought to
be limited to terminally ill people
yeah yeah okay well thank you so much
for giving evidence so that's Dr
Richards down the line Dr Malik and
Professor pest Preston in the room thank
you very much sorry we've slightly
overran but I really appreciate your
candor and your time thank you for
giving evidence this morning order
the proceeding has ended